I think that and I talked about this in
some depth in the book there are two
misperceptions people even very
brilliant people labor under that I
think are really going to keep us from
imagining memory the way we knew we need
to the first is this period of
information inflation that we're living
through is the people think that it's
created by computers and that it's the
first time in history that this has ever
happened this is a moment that's never
happened before
wrong on two counts every information
technology when it's new creates a kind
of vertigo in this case it's a digital
vertigo but as I'll show you there's
always a vertigo and the other
misconception we have is about memory
itself because memory is not data
storage memory in fact is some is a
biological feature of all creatures and
the first step in making robust memories
over time is to forget and the reason
that we have memory to begin with that
make nature has endowed all creatures
with it is because memory is not about
the past it is about the future if we
were born only with DNA we'd all perish
second or third day in life and that's
true even of amoebas so with that I want
to start with talking a little bit about
technology many of you will recognize
this is one of the first and certainly
the most durable information technology
that humans have created it's a clay
tablet also known as a cuneiform you
know technology is a tool that's created
by human beings the technologies have no
powers of their own they only have the
powers that we endow those technologies
with and the technologies especially
around memory are usually invented to
solve a problem or to meet some kind of
a market demand now about five thousand
years ago when the scribes in
Mesopotamia invented these clay tablets
what they were responding to was the
need to keep track of goods and services
in exchange or in storage so they were
basically accountants that invented
writing but within a relatively short
period of time a couple thousand years I
mean Sumerian time that's relatively
quick the technology began to acquire
lots of different capacities and develop
certain potentials in human beings that
were
totally unanticipated by the accountants
another lesson for technologists today
if they think they understand anything
about the uses the future uses of what
they create in fact what they came up
with fairly quickly and this tablet is
about 2700 years old
is uses including prayers and omens if
you could actually read this you know I
just want to point out incidentally that
like the wrote a rosetta stone this is
actually I legible it's a wonderful
technology we can still read it today
and if you did read a Cardian is anybody
in the audience read a Cardian good I'll
get no quizzes on what it says but I do
know that it's filled with divin ocean
and so nations about omens from animals
and human birth defects telling us about
what the future is going to be so if you
were to to be able to read this you
would know that in fact cuneiforms were
very quickly recruited to do something
that accountants never dreamt about and
the first recorded poem that we have the
epic Gilgamesh uses this technology and
as you may know Gilgamesh is actually an
epic about a man who wanted to become
immortal so very appropriate
[Music]